maria dich haben wir schon lange nicht
mehr wie sie german vor der kamera
gesehen wo warst du also hauptsächlich
weil ich in valencia ich bin zwar noch
viel rumgekommen aber ja in valencia war
es eine ganz schön lange zeit im jetzt
bist du zurück in berlin und heute
werden wir welchen frage auf den straße
stellen die frage für heute lautet was
war das verrückteste was du je in einer
u-bahn erlebt hat los geht's
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was ist das verrückteste was sie je nach
u bahn erlebt haben
das verrückteste okay da gibt es in
berlin also alle möglichen aktie von
gewalttätigkeit das war aber nicht so
verrückt nackte leute leute die spontan
gesungen haben diskussion hat man echt
der da halt saß also nachts beim feiern
komplett nackt er komplett nackt sind ja
immer so künstler da und die war es
nämlich die ein instrument spielen oder
so ich hab mal jemand das tryp sondern
ein gut aussehender junger mann das ist
für mich ganz interessant genauso ja
also und dann hat er auch so hart wie
man dann so fragt nach geldsystem
also ich glaube bei mir was tatsache
dass man jemand eine kommode
transportiert hat also zu zweit waren
die und die kommode schien relativ
schwer
ja ich glaube eine alte dame ist
irgendwann mal eine brücke runter
gefallen nur so was also ziemlich kann
nicht die das an also es als one man
band durch den waggon gezogen ist und
alles dabei hatte von trommeln trompeten
triangel und da einfach so einen
kompletten zug unterhalten hat ich habe
mal jemand gesehen der so eine rolle
durch die u-bahn also durch dieses diese
stange oben gemacht ist das war ganz gut
sich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja nach dem pokalfinale vorletztes jahr
kam es dazu krassen verbrüderungsszenen
und das war sehr lustig weil man denkt
ja eigentlich dass fußballfans sich
gegenseitig eher ablehnen aber die lagen
sich da wirklich alle in den armen und
da habe ich zwei männer gesehen die
zweitgrößte ausgetauscht haben und das
waren die waren bestimmt nicht schwul
oder sowie waren einfach nur betrunken
und in feierstimmung das fand ich
irgendwie schon im gleichen verein nehme
die wahren gegner ist das verrückteste
was du je der u bahn erlebt hast dass
jemand dahin gepinkelt hat einfach so in
eine sitzgruppe ja ich habe meinen
mädchen getroffen die wurde von das war
nachts um drei von drei jungs ganz
strikt angesprochen und ich habe mich
dahin gesetzt und habe so getan als
würde ich die kennen der mit jungs weg
gehen wien ett unterfunktion natürlich
sehr ekelhaft ich hatte einmal eine frau
die hat in die u-bahn gepinkelt
da bin ich sofort ausgestiegen und in
anderen sagen weil das fand ich schon
sehr unangenehm nur komische leute die
einfach rauchen und trinken und
vielleicht auch in die u-bahn sich
übergeben
was vielleicht auch täglich mein gott es
fällt mir wird nicht direkt was ein
aber es tatsächlich sehr lustig war war
mal ein flyer da habe ich gefunden weil
ich gedacht habe dass einer seinen schuh
verloren hat und er stand hinter dem
sitzen dass dies an einem nachgetragen
dann hatte gesetzes nicht sein kleiner
sohn sein seinen schuh sondern das ist
ein flyer und dann habe ich dann
aufgemacht und war das ein party flyer
wo leute tatsächlich partys in berlin
über secondhand schuhe promotet haben
die sie in u-bahn versteckt und es war
nicht sehr lustig maria lassen das
solltest du was du je in der u bahn
gesehen hast also für mich war das
verrückteste als ich gegenüber von mir
ein mann hatte und da hat eine packung
mit matt also mit rohem fleisch in der
hand und hat einfach stücke aus dieser
packung genommen und hat die leute damit
abgeworfen hat sich selbst noch mit in
den mund geschoben
und ja das war total komisch haben auch
versucht uns dann alle so ein bisschen
zu entfernen es gab dann noch eine frau
die wir total verängstigt dass sie jetzt
auch ein stück fleisch abbekommt und
meinte noch bitte mich nicht abwerfen
ich bin vegetarier und hat das geholfen
ich glaube nicht wirklich hat es nicht
weiter verfolgt
[Musik]
ich fand es sehr witzig als ein rapper
kam und der hat einen sicher rapper
kunden sowie ihr die leute angeschaut
hat dann hat er irgendwas vor sich hin
geräumt und deshalb war auch sehr
passend eine mexikanische reggae band
die in der ringbahn zehn stunden am
stück den cantina song von star wars
gespielt hat und wer weiß das schon über
hunt es war so fasziniert und gefesselt
dass ich einfach nicht ausstehen konnte
ich wollte einfach dabei sein und alles
ja ich wollte einfach nicht ausstehen
und und sie meine ausgezogen die hosen
runtergelassen schon meinen augen
und das waren man ja manchmal zu bauen
und ja ich habe mal so einen typen
gesehen der hat das irgendwie der hat so
an diesen stangenrod und so ist so hat
so angefangen so da halt irgendwo
kunststücke zu machen so folgt total ja
so ein bisschen also nicht unbedingt
paul der ems habe hat halt angefangen
sich daran irgendwie aufzuhängen so dass
mit einer vollen urban 42 das war
bestimmt nicht das witzigste was man
passieren dass ja aber das habe ich
einfach vergessen das verrückteste oder
das schrecklich vielleicht geht es ja
beides zusammen und das wird tatsächlich
seien angriffe auf ausländer das habe
ich erleben auf na ja türkische mit
kinderwagen
er war ziemlich betrunken auch nicht
ganz normal aber das für mich komisch so
war das ja die ganze zeit an gemeckert
hat man soll ich was ich vergessen was
weiß ich und keiner sagt was ist und ich
gucke alle anderen gehen wie und dann
geht die tür auf und ich sage ihnen so
jetzt reicht und sie gehen hier raus und
wenn man sogar securities die ich dann
irgendwie auch gerufen habe und dann
haben ich weiß nicht ob dann jemand zu
mir kam oder mich angelächelt danach
aber dass er das wirklich schlimmste
komme ich sage ich wurde mal wird in
eine schlägerei schlägereien verwickelt
und was haben sie dafür eine rolle
gespielt die in der männer neben mir
haben sich angefangen zu schlagen
ich musste dann schon in deckung gehen
und dann beim nächsten beim nächsten
halt schnell aussteigen
ansonsten hätte ich da auch noch mit
einer abbekommen
also es ihnen aber nichts passieren
wirklich vor ort doch eine sache war da
war eine band die außergewöhnlich gute
musik gemacht habe aber das war jetzt
nicht unbedingt verrückt aber es hat mir
sehr gefallen
auf dem weg von der arbeit nach hause
hat es mich sehr relaxed nicht unbedingt
verrückt aber schön das witzigste
spontan fällt mir nur ein das einfach
irgendwie nachts um 3 uhr wir in der u
bahn sitzen dann kommt ein kontrolleur
die fahrkarten sehen von irgendwie drei
leuten ja jetzt habt ihr all die
verrückten geschichten gehört und jetzt
seid ihr dran
wir wollen von euch eure folgten
geschichten wissen was habt ihr mal
verrückt ist in der u bahn gesehen in
berlin oder auch in eurer heimatstadt
schreibt uns unbedingt einen kommentar
und wenn ihr jetzt noch weiter deutsch
lernen wollt dann würden wir euch
unbedingt unsere erzielen empfehlen denn
auf siedlungen könnt ihr auch viele
geschichten sehen auch ein paar
verrückte geschichten sehen und ihr
könnt dabei eure aus sprache lernen und
neue grammatik und neue wörter spielend
kennenlernen probiert das mal aus wir
freuen uns auf euch und wir sehen uns
nächste woche wieder oder ja klar
[Musik]